wow what an episode what a way to end
season one on like the biggest
cliffhanger ever
it was ah just the way it ended it was
like oh my god
like i was so sure like i it felt like
we were gonna give a cliffhanger like
just because of the direction the show
was going in it felt like it could
continue on for like another hour or
like a whole another series of events
instead it's just like loki will return
in season two and so now we know the
entire plot behind season two
but something that i want to get out of
the way right now the guy they were
talking to right the guy that jonathan
majors played in the show that sylvie
and loki were talking to
that was not king to conquer
well it was but it wasn't
let's talk about a guy called immortus
so in the marvel cinematic universe with
regards to this explanation
of this guy being a scientist from the
31st century much of that is pretty much
the exact same except kane the conqueror
originates from the 30th century in
marvel comics i don't really know why
they chose 31st instead of 30th but at
the end of the day it doesn't really
matter all that much
much like what you saw the guy was just
kind of living in his timeline but kang
ultimately got bored with his life and
discovered the ability to time travel
and so what he did in the comics is he
traveled into the past
to ancient egypt and gave himself the
name of rama tut now during this time he
faced off against characters like
apocalypse and he faced off against
doctor strange
but most notably he faced off against
the fantastic four
and what the fantastic four ended up
doing was in defeating him
basically forcing him back to his
timeline he was supposed to go back to
the 30th century
and then basically chalk up his attempts
to go into the past is essentially a
failure cast aside the name of rahmatut
go back to being k in the conquer that
was supposed to be it instead he ended
up stopping in the modern era facing off
against some superheroes for a while
and then ended up in a realm called
limbo now limbo exists in two forms of
marvel comics
there's the demonic realm of limbo then
there is the actual realm of limbo the
demonic realm of limbo is the one that's
ran by magic also known as ileana
rasputin you may or may not see that in
the mcu i honestly have no idea but the
actual realm of limbo is really what you
think of when you think of limbo right a
purgatory-like place
that exists outside of space and time
now for those of you guys who have been
doing some reading
outside of the loki tv show probably
doing it online or watching my videos or
comics explained or whatever you've
probably heard of a giant city called
chronopolis
and a castle of sorts in chronopolis
called tenebree that's the realm
of immortus the way this works is that
when rama tut traveled to limbo
he looked throughout the time stream and
saw that there were two possible futures
for himself the first is that he would
go back to his life as king
and the second is that he would become
an agent of the time keepers
and that in working for the time keepers
his job would be to ensure
that he essentially pruned the timeline
and made sure
that they came into existence he didn't
like the idea of working for the time
keepers
so he went back to being kang and then
kang went forward and did a whole bunch
of other stuff across marvel comics
but there is an alternate universe where
ramat stayed
in limbo and did become an agent of the
timekeepers and that guy became immortus
now immortus's role in marvel comics was
pretty simple
unlike king the conqueror who basically
traveled throughout the time stream
and faced off against various people
immortus largely just stayed in limbo
we'll talk about why that matters here
in a second he had a few interesting
stories here and there things like the
celestial madonna
the idea of avengers forever and so on
and so forth but overall the idea of
immortus was to look at the nature of
kang and to come to the realization
that kang was screwing up the time
stream so let's talk about kang for a
second
so if a mortise was a version of kang
who existed in limbo
and monitored what king prime as you can
call him was basically doing
then what kang prime was doing was
running throughout the different points
in the time stream
one of the things we covered in the
video that we did hear about the
multiverse explain in regards to marvel
comics here on gig culture explain
is we talked about the idea that
traveling into the past is not enough to
create an alternate reality in mobile
comics it's one of the big differences
between the comics and the mcu
just the very act of traveling into the
past or anywhere into the time stream
outside of where you're supposed to be
is enough to create a branch of universe
in the marvel cinematic universe so
there's kind of a big difference there
but in order to actually create an
alternate reality in marvel comics you
have to do a thing so kane the conqueror
could face off against the avengers and
then a whole
litany of alternate realities will
basically emerge based on
what possibilities could take place and
how that fight with the avengers could
go
and so because kane the conqueror had
done this on multiple occasions
throughout the history of the time
stream it led to him creating a ton of
alternate realities
and all these different alternate
realities basically had different
versions of kang
that had different scenarios about them
some of whom destroyed the avengers
some of whom got the infinity gauntlet
and destroyed the universe or
bent the universe to their whim some of
which conquered the entirety of their
universe but regardless of the situation
you had what was in effect
a council of kings now the kangs
themselves stretched on for a pretty
lengthy amount of time
and much like what you saw in the marvel
cinematic universe in the loki show
with the role of immortus which was
coming to this realization that all
these kings waging war against each
other essentially would have resulted in
the destruction of everything
that basically all the different kings
were defeated and mortis seemed to be
the last man standing
and in doing so created the tva as a
means to make sure
that no other branch universes would
emerge and that in ensuring that's the
case
no other kangs would pop up and so what
you have here is a situation
where jonathan majors is basically
immortus the issue is that jonathan
mages is now dead
he was killed by sylvie which means the
multiverse is now just kind of going
into full flux
and there's a few things that come out
of this right
the first and foremost let's talk about
what happened with
loki so loki himself was of course
pushed through the portal by sylvie
and ended up in this place where when he
went to meet with
mobius and b15 and kind of this
revelation of what was going on
they didn't remember who he was the
reason for that is because
loki's in an alternate reality and we
can deduce that he's in this alternate
reality for a couple different reasons
one we can say that he was inadvertently
pushed into an alternate universe by
sylvie
or we can say that when ravana rinslayer
basically went through her portal that
she ended up likely going into the past
and changing things regardless of how
you slice it loki's not in the same
universe now let's say that ravana
renaissance went into the past and she
altered things right she decided that
she wanted to work with kane the
conqueror
as opposed to working for kane the
conqueror and is basically fulfilling
her role as she exists in the comics
and really just kind of being a love
interest did you guys ever see the movie
deep impact where that giant meteor
crashed into the ocean and said this
giant tidal wave
just careening in virtually every
direction that's how changes in the time
stream work in this instance
ravana rinse layer is potentially the
asteroid hitting the water
and the changes to the time stream or
the tidal wave moving towards its final
destination
that's how this sort of thing works it's
a cascading effect
and so if ravana rensselaer went into
the past and she decided to work with
kang
once the multiverse was restored and
then in turn made it easier for
a particular version of king to become
this kind of person that basically found
the tva
instead of a mortise basically they won
the multiverse award then suddenly
everything shifts and everything changes
that while the events more or less
transpire the same throughout the
history of the loki show it's kane the
conqueror that you see as the statue at
the end of the show
instead of just a random time keeper the
entire timeline has shifted now let's
say for example that what's actually
going on here
is that loki was pushed into an
alternate reality by
sylvie how would this play out how would
it explain everything well one
it makes things a lot easier one of the
things to understand when it comes to
alternate realities in mobile comics and
by extension
at least to a degree the marvel
cinematic universe is that everything in
that universe
before that point where it branches off
stays the same
so say for example that you had an
alternate reality where peter parker
never became spider-man
everything up to that point in that
universe is still the same
it's just at that critical moment when
peter was supposed to be bitten by a
radioactive spider he went to the
bathroom instead and was never bitten by
that spider and then never became
spider-man instead maybe it was somebody
like wouldn't stacy or
or flash thompson or something along
those lines who really knows who really
cares but everything up to that point
is still the exact same and so if sylvie
pushed loki back to a point
where he basically ended up in an
alternate universe it's easy to slide
between one and the other
if you have something like a portal
maybe it's just one of these things
where he was kind of
shoved in that direction and that's
basically it we don't definitively know
it's just one of these things where it
just kind of seems to have branched off
one of the things to keep in mind is
that if you're in one of these finer
little nexus points
it's easy for you to just kind of slide
into an alternate reality
without being able to keep yourself in
the main universe but there's all kinds
of possibilities here how the marvel
cinematic universe
treats time travel is in a lot of ways
different from how marvel comics handles
it
makes a lot more sense which is
certainly a much much better thing but
at the end of the day the loki's show
was amazing like it was absolutely
awesome here's one of the funny things
though one of the big issues that a lot
of people are struggling with is
when loki takes place it's very very
easy for us to look at the loki tv show
and see that it comes after events like
avengers end game and infinity war
in terms of when marvel created it but
just because of the fact that the movie
was released after infinity war does not
mean it takes place
after the events of infinity war that
the tva exists in null space right
there's no time there
and so to impact the multiverse means to
impact the entire timeline
and so look at one division for a second
the post-credits scene
the idea that wanda basically heard the
voices of her kids and then took off
after it to basically find out what was
going on
it's entirely possible that her hearing
that coincides with the creation of the
multiverse and that once the multiverse
was formed there's now an alternate
reality out there where she was where
her kids basically survived
and that if we know somebody like
schumachorath and doctor strange 2 is
going to be a major villain
and schumacherath is aware of that and
given the history of his character that
he's aware of like nexus beings like
juan
maximoff it wouldn't be that hard if he
exists in the multiversal space
to reach out to wanda and trick her into
believing that her kids are alive but in
danger
and she has to go save them and then
capture her right these are the kind of
possibilities that can come
out of the loki tv show these are the
kind of things that you could be seeing
i don't know if we definitively will but
it is an awesome concept
regardless at the end of the day the
loki show was amazing i absolutely loved
it it was a fantastic show i had a great
time watching it
and i am very very very excited for
season two but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace